okay I gotta go thanks for taking care
of her dad she loves having you around
it is the bottom of the ball
really you never tell your old papaw I
wanna graze amusement parks of all time
those days were different they won't so
many rules
your mom would come for the summer when
she was the voice of reason you're the
lifeguard should we keep facing the
water let God sort em out what's our
attendance today down about 45 percent
what I suppose you've probably heard you
got some competition in town
they got roller coasters and a chairlift
that actually works this is our home
can't just like somebody take it what
this place needs is an excitement enema
we're gonna make this place fast and
loose every ride
every attraction no rules must be like
just pure [ __ ] that sounds kind of
dangerous let's see what this baby can
do
[Music]
we need some to do these little bastards
like a petting zoo hold my beer
[Applause]
[Music]
not as younger I could do or these
[Music]
[Music]